The Hound's name and chess drama
continues chess.com had previously said
they believe that Hans is not being
truthful about the amount and
seriousness of him cheating on their
site this week they released a 72-page
report to back up that claim saying they
believe that Hans has likely cheated in
over a hundred online games Hans has
simply said he's not going to back down
let's get into it
[Music]
all right just before we jump into this
for those of you who don't know we have
merch now we've got a whole new range of
clothes for you to go and check out my
favorite is the touch grass hoodie it's
just a nice reminder you know you just
you're gonna touch grass sometimes okay
so if you don't know the story after
this point I'm gonna sum it up very
quickly for you if you're looking for
more details though I have done two very
lengthy videos about this topic already
the Chess World was shocked on September
4th when 19 year old American
Grandmaster Hans Neiman beat Magnus
Carlson the 31 year old world champion
who many believe to be the greatest
chess player of all time the next day
Magnus announced here withdrawn from the
tournament and included a clip of
football manager Jose Mourinho not
wanting to speak his mind in an
interview I prefer really not to
not to speak if I speak I am in in big
trouble
in big trouble and I don't want to be in
big trouble the implication that many
people took from this was that Magnus
thought Hans had been cheating some
people said they found hans's analysis
of the game in a post-match interview to
be suspiciously insufficient others said
Hans had risen up the world rankings way
too quickly in recent years that there
was something unnatural about his
massive ELO gains for a player already
nearing the elites now Hans admitted to
cheating in informal online games when
he was 12 and 16 years old but stressed
that he would never cheat again
especially in an over-the-board game
such as the one with Magnus and most
importantly there was no concrete proof
of him cheating against Magnus and
nobody could provide a solid suggestion
for how he even would have done that one
theory that picked up a lot of attention
was that Hans made use of anal beads
which would send vibrating signals to
him as a guide for his next move the
drama continued on September 19th when
the pair faced off again in the Julius
bear generation cup only for Magnus to
resign in protest after a single all
move sorry Alejandra I just have to
interrupt you because the game started
um and Magnus has logged off what has
happened Magnus has resigned
Magnus has to resigned the game against
Hans Neiman a week later Magnus spoke
out for the first time on everything
stating he believed Hans had cheated
more and more recently than he has
publicly admitted and that he was not
willing to play against him and that in
a nutshell brings us up to this week
when on Tuesday chess.com released what
they described as their official report
on Hans Neiman Magnus Carlson and
cheating in chess now for those of you
that don't know chess.com is a major
online chess platform that hosts a lot
of tournaments and has some strong
connections with famous chess players
and streamers now around the time the
whole Magnus drama began chess.com
Uninvited Hans from their Global
championship event and some people found
that a little bit sus given that the
jury was out and it's still out on the
Magnus game in the reports opening
paragraphtress.com state that the report
is intended to be an exploration of the
events circumstances and data that have
informed their decisions concerning the
current controversy they also open by
saying that they believe Hans likely
cheated in online games more than he's
admitted but that quote while Hans has
had a record setting and remarkable rise
in rating and strength in our view there
is a lack of concrete statistical
evidence that he cheated in his game
with Magnus or in any other
over-the-board I.E in-person games so
for those of you that thought that
chess.com was going to come flying out
of left field with solid hard concrete
proof of Hans Neiman cheating against
Magnus in that game
yeah it's it's not that they stressed
that Magnus had no say or even knowledge
about their decision to revoke Khan's
invitation to their Global championship
and that it was due to their experience
with him in the past growing suspicions
among top players and their team about
his rapid rise of play the strange
circumstances and explanations of his
win over Magnus as well as magnus's
withdrawal from the tournament now one
factor a lot of this report hinges on is
chess.com disputing something that we've
actually discussed a lot in these videos
so far Hans Neiman's assertion that
other than the two times he's already
admitted to cheating when he was 12 and
16 years old he has never and would
never cheat in a tournament with prize
money and to put it quite simply
chess.com are calling massive
on this they said they aim to show with
this report that Hans cheated against
multiple opponents in chess.com prize
events speed Chess Championship
qualifiers and the pro chess League
claim they have evidence that Hans
cheated in rated games against high
rated well-known figures in in the chess
scene some of which he streamed at the
time they say their internal analytical
fair play Team gathered detailed
evidence on hans's play and determined
that there were numerous games where
hans's gameplay crossed a line onto a
certain Spectrum now on the one side of
the spectrum our chess players that are
obviously cheating every single move
they make is the top move that a chess
engine would recommend you to take now
even the best pro players can't manage
to do this consistently in every game
for multiple games so it's a pretty
clear indicator of someone cheating now
at the other end of this spectrum are
players that are making unusually
sophisticated moves that have left the
bounds of statistical probability so
what does that mean what it means that
players in this group are finding these
top chess engine moves more than they
should be able to on average it's not
absolutely certain that they're cheating
of course but it's pretty likely
it's in this category the chess.com who
plays Hans Neiman they then provided a
very important table here that details
all the events where they believe hans's
play left the realm of statistical
possibility the later events took place
mostly in 2020 and the earliest alleged
case dates back to 2015 when Hans was
just 12. they state that they have found
that Hans had likely cheated in more
than 100 online chess games and that 25
of these he actually streamed himself
the report then recounts a private phone
call from 2020 between Hans and Danny
wrench the CCO of chess.com now in the
call Hans was allegedly informed that
they'd be closing his accounts due to
the suspected cheating in the games
we've just talked about they said that
during this call Hans confessed to the
cheating offenses and contacted them
over slack to ask about how to move
forward from there and they shared this
slack conversation beginning on August
12 2020 it starts by showing a
conversation about Hans voluntarily
closing his account after receiving his
six-month ban to allegedly save face
public
he is also told where to send a written
statement acknowledging the offense and
promising to not repeat it finally we
see Hans requesting in November 2020 to
be unbanned temporarily in order to
compete in the U.S chess qualifiers
Danny said that was not possible but
allowed him to rejoin their famous
tilted Tuesday events in one moment of
foreshadowing Hans admits he's afraid to
over perform as an I am since it hurts
him to have his play questioned the
report also outlines what chess.com
describes as their Best in Class cheat
detection system now they say it's
exposed many players in its 15-year plus
long history including dozens of GMS and
four players from the fide top 100.
their system aims to expose selective
cheating and the idea behind this is
actually pretty simple the best players
in the world don't actually need to
cheat for every single move to go from
really really good to pretty much
Invincible they might only need to
achieve two or three times in a game to
achieve that and of course this
selective cheating is a lot harder to
detect than someone cheating on every
single move chess.com say their system
digs deep into the probability that a
player can achieve a result given their
past performances this is referred to as
a player's aggregate strength score it's
on a scale of 0 to 150 with 150 meaning
every single move a player makes is
perfect according to a chess engine they
say 90 is the highest score they've ever
seen the top player naturally sustain
across games 100 is the highest they've
ever measured a human in a single game
and someone using a Pure Chess engine
depending on the complexity of it would
find himself between 125 and 150. they
provided this table which included a
list of anonymous Grandmasters who
confessed that they cheated to chess.com
and almost right in the middle there we
have Hans Neiman his score of 85.5 is
close to the absolute record for a human
over multiple games according to
chess.com system now this might not seem
too noteworthy until you look at the
GM's low him in strength score who as we
just mentioned have admitted to cheating
now it's important to know that there
were Grandmasters on there with higher
strength scores than him as well and
that this sort of thing is only supposed
to flag a player for further study it
doesn't mean case close by itself from
there the report gets into talking about
hans's rapid rise in rating which they
ultimately say they can't be decisive on
one way or the other adding that their
investigation found no red flags in the
rise of his over-the-board ranking now
in the appendix some of the graphs they
shared of players strength versus their
age did make it look like Hans has never
slowed down or leveled off like you'd
expect to see with other chess Pros
although that could simply be to do with
his age none of these other graphs look
like shooting stars right
like they they all they all have some
flat lens this is literally a straight
gapp up
this is literally a straight Gap up
right it's like literally it's it's like
uh non-stop it's straight up they did
also touch on that Infamous singfield
Cup game with Magnus but to be honest no
new ground was really covered for me
they mentioned one of magnus's early
moves which Hans counted extremely well
and later said in an interview that he
had prepared specifically for chess.com
pointed out that Magnus hadn't actually
played that move for over 10 years and
he also mentioned that Hans didn't reach
the standard of high-level players when
analyzing his own game after the event
in their conclusion they State their
investigation has quote revealed that
while there has been some noteworthy
online play that has caught our
attention as suspicious since August
2020 they were unaware of any evidence
that Hans have engaged in online
cheating since then but they added that
their investigation has quotes concluded
that he did however cheat much more than
he has publicly admitted to including in
many prize events at least 25 stream
games and 100 Plus ratedgames on
chess.com as recently as when he was 17
years old so where are we now well it's
important to know that we still don't
have any concrete proof that says Hans
cheated in his game versus Magnus but we
also don't have anything to absolve him
either the importance of the chess.com
Rapport is that they have provided what
they believe to be evidence that Hans
has not only cheated more recently than
he told us but that he's lied about it
too and seeing us so much of this
revolves around people's gut feelings
and suspicions it's definitely not the
best time for this to happen even if he
was innocent in the Magnus game for me
this tweet from chessable CEO Gert
vanderveld summed it up quite well by
saying Hans cheated online as a teenager
Magnus lost the game around two and a
half years later to him Magnus then
accused Hans publicly of cheating now
Magnus has provided no evidence for this
dress.com published a report on hans's
cheating two and a half years ago
perhaps more poetically Grandmaster
Jonathan Rosen said Hans both cheated
and didn't sheet he lied and he didn't
lie he has been fairly treated and
unfairly treated he has himself to blame
and others to blame such is life we're
in the world of both and and either or
now time to get used to it while the
rest of the world has been focusing on
the report Hans has been playing in the
2022 U.S chess championships on
Wednesday he took down Christopher you
in round one in his post-match interview
he let everyone know that now his chess
is doing the talking for him well um I
think that this game is a
is a message to everyone and uh you know
this entire thing started with me saying
chess speaks for itself and I think this
game spoke for itself and showed the
chess player that I am and it also
showed that um I'm not going to back
down and I'm going to play my best chess
here in some ways this chess report is
obviously damaging to Hans Neiman a
major chess network has said with
confidence that he has treated in
hundreds of games that's not a great
look but on the other hand they can't
categorically prove that that's not
their fault either it's just the nature
of cheating in chess not everything is
provable and there's still nothing to
prove conclusively that he cheated in
that game versus Magnus last month
chess.com even say they can't confirm
order neither there's a lot more for us
to chew on now 72 pages of it in fact
but in some ways this drama is just as
messy just as bizarre and just as
unsolved as it's always been
oh my God I'm gonna lose my mind here
it's literally right in front of my face
it's not even like behind my head it's
constantly in my face
well at least you got some funny onboard
stuff now